This is the end of this class, you got
all the way to the end, congratulations,
Quite an achievement. Now you've gotten a
taste of how great artificial intelligence is.
Here in Silicon Valley, we use AI for everything.
Google, Facebook, Amazon, all these
companies use AI at their core and they use
machine learning
to remake the the experience for the
user
great. So if you go a step further and
challenge yourself
and take additional classes in this
field, you can become
a great great employees in here
Silicon Valley and find a job at least
in the tech industry. But for
the time being, congratulations,
you made it to the end, it's quite an
achievement. Get some rest.